-I'd like to take a moment to
thank some of our sponsors
for tonight's show.
They don't always get to fit
in the commercial breaks,
and we want to make sure that
we mention all of them,
so it's time for
"Tonight Show Sponsors."
Here we go.
-♪ Tonight Show sponsors ♪
♪ Tonight Show sponsors ♪
[ Applause ]
-Arby's. Why roast beef?
Well, first of all, thanks
for assuming that it is.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Shell -- Our gas is now 50 cents
higher than it was
at the beginning
of this sentence.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Michelin -- We make tires
and review restaurants.
It just makes sense.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Pita Chips --
Don't have any hummus?
LOL, enjoy.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Hewlett-Packard -- We're pretty
much screwed whenever
Apple decides to make printers.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Wells Fargo --
Oh, you want to withdraw $20?
That'll be $35.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Alka-Seltzer -- Plop, plop,
fizz, fizz, sorry for the noise.
We know you're hungover.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Expo Dry Erase Markers --
Always works the first time.
The second time? Well, that's
where the game begins.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Go-Gurt -- Ever wanted to "milk"
your afternoon snack
out of a plastic udder?
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Udder.
-Bed, Bath, and Beyond --
We've got everything you'll
throw away next time you move.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Also sponsored by crypto.com.
Hey, does anybody want to buy
a basketball arena?
[ Laughter and applause ]
Ann Taylor --
Be a lady in the streets,
a coastal grandma in the sheets.
[ Laughter and applause ]
IKEA -- furniture guaranteed to
fall apart slightly less quickly
than your relationship.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Trader Joe's -- Oh, you like
that thing you bought here?
Oh, we'll never carry it again.
[ Laughter and applause ]
And finally, Twitter --
The countdown to you
getting fired over something
you said on here starts...now.
There you go. Thank you, all of
our "Tonight Show" sponsors.
Thank you very much.